if she believed the fifth weekend two
icons Carly and Aaron thank you so much
for blessing me today with your presence
I mean what a treat what a treat
you know I was so happy walking in and
seeing you wear this nice surprise
I am a Stan candy is my new favorite
line it's so cute fun to see people
actually wearing them and just like
taking nice like it was really funny
because we keep getting so many comments
that like my dog just realized that C
and E it's funny like everyone coming to
that realization and we're kind of
worried that it wouldn't catch on or
like if people wouldn't read it the
right way yeah the origin story for
candy it's pretty iconic yeah
can you tell us a little bit about it
again because what a great it's such a
youtube thing yeah so when you do brand
deals like advertisements or YouTube you
usually have a code you have to say so
people can type it in and get a discount
or something and for I think it was Adam
and Eva so yeah which is like a sexy nd
that would be so cool like candy Carly
and Aaron and just like stick it on a
shirt or something and then we just like
brainstormed a bunch of different ideas
with it you guys are already working on
what's coming next
yeah the line I never made a whole
collection at the very beginning and
Relic okay we'll release these three
first then like the fall will come
around and we'll put out these which I'm
really excited about yeah so yeah
there's a lot in the works really
excited how does it feel officially
biggest style icons I mean watch out
they're away I feel like just for the
whole group like all you guys have had
such a really big year I mean you guys
hit a million that's a huge milestone
how was life change since becoming
millionaires I mean we bought Cartier
ring it's really cool to see that and
like I feel like ours was such a slow
build so it was really exciting when we
finally yeah and I think we appreciate
it because we've been working for it for
so long
yeah as Kylie Jenner gonna be in the
test and your Tesla Nexus with Chris
tomorrow I win the head and I made sure
that your honeymoon is taken care of up
to ten thousand dollars
you guys can go wherever you want and
you can't have a honeymoon without a
wedding so here's $40,000 now that David
surprised you my pain right he told me
that he wants to be very very involved
with the process now has that happened
[Music]
it's funny I spent all day Saturday of
dressing my save the dates to like yeah
so that was it's pretty crazy I feel
like especially I would never know how
much a wedding is before you start
planning it yeah so once we finally like
started doing everything I was like what
do you mean and things so funny that
what are you gonna do like something
crazy know that like David gave you all
this money I'm like yeah I'm gonna just
have a normal wedding because that's all
are you already thinking about the
content that's gonna come out of the
wedding at all has I've been in the back
of your mind like you know you guys have
three videos a day like yeah are we a
week sorry
a week you really got it you gotta
capitalize on you guys I mean it's
definitely it's cool because when we do
do wedding themed videos I feel like
they do really well because everyone
it's it's a lot different than what we
would normally do yeah I think no one in
our friend group has gone down that path
yet so it's pretty interesting I'm
hoping I'm letting people film at the
wedding because I feel like it's good
memories yes to just as long as David
doesn't bring like a 300 foot bail okay
yeah but yeah free rein fun whatever and
Carly I know you recently opened up
about your breakup and I'm like it must
be hard because people get so invested
in your guys's friendships and
relationships where you hesitant I also
tell your followers about that like
almost a month cuz I'm just like I just
don't want everyone responding to it and
like reminding you but it wasn't as bad
as I thought it was gonna be but it
definitely is weird when so many people
because like for a while people were
just like did they break up break up or
like what's going on and but yeah it
felt good to just like put it out there
and kind of just close that I guess yeah
just like how people know for sure
what's going on yeah yeah it's weird
when it's public cuz like obviously like
David and Liza went through that but
it's like on such a different scale so I
was like okay I kind of get like how it
plays out a little bit at least yeah
yeah but it hasn't been bad I was
expecting like negative comments to me
or him or whatever I don't think it's
really been as bad as I thought it was
yeah it must be tough because even in
your friendships like if someone is in
in the in David's vlog people assume
that there's just huge falling out or
whatever yeah does that kind of does
that affect your real-life friendships
at all all the kind of the gossip of the
rumors are that you do guys pretty much
like stay far from it I think we all
know what's real and what's not real so
it's easy for us to just kind of like be
like oh haha
they're always yeah but other than that
I don't think it really affects you that
are just like people are gonna say what
they want to say yeah chairs and some
people come and go but it's not like a
negative thing either yeah it's like
something bad happened it's just
sometimes it does go I feel like it's
only right
I have you guys here that we do addition
of log squad gossip you've really
created quite a mix a question so listen
if anyone could give us the true T it's
definitely you chewing yeah this one
really killed me this is from your
recent video someone commented on the
tumblr are we witnessing Carly falling
for Jason just shown the locks lock ah
so you guys did with Jason's there is
one Charlie Charlie could be Jason Jonah
[Music]
it's like any time that one of the girls
like talks to it guys like she's like my
dad we are pretty obsessed with him as a
person yeah whatever
he's coming over okay he's probably the
funniest one when Jason goes out of town
when is Jason coming yeah but we're
officially debunking okay Oh
controversial is Aaron's natural hair
curly or straight really was helping me
organize you guys over the edge I'm
really confused by all of this so I just
this was just a general thing that I
need you guys to clear up why do so many
people ship David and Natalie I don't
know I think I also do when they're even
friends forever yeah and their dynamic
is so great and they're both
good-looking people I don't know I mean
it's it's funny but we all love Natalie
and I know he they're like brother and
sister that's so interesting yeah it's
like behind the scenes like we see their
real relations
line is just like googly I hear them
yeah but like any time we're like don't
guys are not dating like they're just
friends like we get people look why are
you not shipping that but like you know
like people who ship other yeah yeah
yeah they go down with this [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's funny too cuz when like people
like say that they're willing you know
like no never
they're truly brother and sister they
bicker and there's some wild conspiracy
theories about Illya
kissing Natalie in Chicago and that's
why and everyone's fighting I don't know
I think there was like someone took a
video of David like saying he was like
up something they can get it on camera
yeah like the only reason David would
ever be mad at that is because he
couldn't a very crazy one did Todd
really accidentally flashed the camera
and one of Jason's recent videos no no
did you not put that in no cuz he didn't
know if he wanted it in so I just that's
right it was like a string in the
costume that everyone thought was his
penis yeah and Jesus always like so
known for keeping things in that he
shouldn't because you know it's Jason
and every way like you couldn't even
tell like it wasn't like Todd was like
direct front and center on the year wait
in the background and he's like a string
flopped out of his costume that he was
wearing there was like his penis okay
and then like Todd was like that wasn't
my penis like I'm wearing boxers like it
was a little string now his costume so
that's really fun have you guys
accidentally left something in a vlog or
video that you had to go back and check
out or nothing bad I think but jason has
uploaded a video and Zane's nut was
sitting on a couch like this just like
this and when you can see it you're like
oh my god and they actually one time he
accidentally uploaded it it was me Aaron
and Zayn just having a conversation but
like we were felt he was filming so but
like in between we always say things
that are like
Crazy's obviously we would never put on
the internet just like to around some
tea we should I didn't watch I was too
scared but I deleted it it's been up for
like 10 minutes oh and I was like I
thought it was a video because his video
was 13 minutes and the clip was 13
minutes so I was like what happened to
that girl with her dog yeah yeah David
thought his marriage was more legitimate
than Jake Antanas what do you guys think
about Jake Antanas wedding I mean I feel
like ever it's just faint not even
married I mean it's just for cloud like
it'll be funny that's like good for them
like if they want to but don't sound
like an Oprah impersonator there so I
really had like some standards to live
up to we'd always stream lawyers for
$50.00 like I know I don't think you
want to that's like so obvious that it
wasn't real like for me it's such a
personal moment like I just want my
family in front and like the people who
are closest to me like obviously it'd be
amazing to make a quick buck that I
could like pay for everything sure but
like I feel like it's so invasive and
like it wouldn't be like weird yeah the
Royal Wedding doesn't thank you barks
five gossip professionals I was for sure
I mean you created the franchise it's so
funny yeah I think as girls we like
gossip like not really like being a part
of it but just like hearing it and
seeing it especially when people talk
about fun yeah interesting and it's just
weird I don't know it's fun to like say
it public like on YouTube and be able to
be like no this isn't true actually
yeah I can't believe it I almost forgot
this question before I let you guys go
how's Bobby doing I know you guys don't
get over there as much right now yeah
but I personally just always missed a
look at Bobby cameo like whoa no I feel
like we're so scared whenever we go now
that we wait so long one cuz we don't
get as much to our peel box anymore and
we live a lot farther than they used to
so whenever we go we're like oh my god
please don't be mad at us he's good yeah
he's crying we probably once a month now
and it's funny cuz people get really
excited about it and they come on but
he's good I hope he doesn't retire
anytime I know he's so sweet Livie
invited to your wedding okay
[Music]